hurricane Irma it is leaving a path of
destruction like we have never seen
before to take a look at these dramatic
images of hurricane armor pounding
several islands in the Caribbean with
sustained 185 mile per hour winds that
completely ripped apart buildings and
homes and airports and even the
infrastructure here's the aftermath in
Saint Maarten most everything in
hurricane earnest path was completely
leveled leaving debris and destruction
everywhere then there's a neighboring
island Barbuda now the country's prime
minister compared this hurricane hitting
to a bomb being dropped on a city
officials are saying get this 95 percent
of buildings and vehicles have been
destroyed and just to give you an idea
of just how dangerous and unprecedented
the storm is let's take a look at some
of the headlines around the country CBS
Miami Miami Beach mayor urges residents
to get out now quote this is a nuclear
hurricane Yahoo News Hermer will be
devastating for the u.s. emergency chief
USA Today hurricane Irma has the
potential of affecting every major city
in Florida the new york post hurricane
Irma is the size of Texas Miami Herald
to South Florida nuclear power plants
lie in Emma's path are they ready scary
thought and back to CBS Miami Dade
residents find some pumps Drive water in
short supply Washington Post US military
preparations for hurricane Irma now
include get this for Navy ships and
thousands of troops and The Daily Beast
hurricane Irma is stronger than all of
2017 other eight Atlantic storms
combined that's how serious this storm
is tonight joining us now on the phone
is the Florida Governor Rick Scott
governor first our thoughts and prayers
are with you sir I've been watching you
and and clearly every preparation
possible I see is in effect let's talk
to the people that in the path of the
storm tonight what do you want to say to
them John I sort about every every
person lives in our state I want
everybody to be safe so the most
important thing is get prepared follow
the news if you're an infatuation area
in fact wait immediately I'm gonna do
everything
can you provide the fuel so you can get
out I've been working with the oil
companies with the carriers with the
retailer's I'm providing law enforcement
escorts to get more fuel into the state
we have three more tankers come into
Tampa the port Tampa the white house
FEMA EPA Department of Transportation is
part of energy everybody is helping us
come on everybody to be stay safe this
is a massive storm as you said it packs
a lot of wind here's the little big
difference this is way bigger than
answers 25 years ago it's bigger in size
bigger than wind and so way bigger and
storm surge you could see storm surge
covers your entire house that didn't
happen with a doubt everybody's got to
take this seriously governor if you look
at the cone and you look at the model
now I know what you expect this to first
hit South Florida and and that means
basically from Miami and then to the
west up to Fort Myers and maybe even
Sarasota and on the East Coast I know
that you're going to be hitting West
Palm and and even above that Broward
County is now being evacuated I the
important thing is the whole state is
engulfed and people are evacuating to
the middle of the state is the middle of
the state in your estimation safe enough
absolutely
oh we're follow your local evacuation
orders we have shelters in every county
in most cases you don't have to leave
your County we have safe shelters in
your County so you can you can stay in
your County but many people further
north we're following all the traffic
highways patrol our department
transportation we're making sure all our
evacuation routes that are open but a
big thing it is with you if you're going
to exactly doing this early as possible
because the later you do this the more
traffic you're going to run into but you
can build your shelters we have them in
every county to keep okay yeah
governor what are the things I did call
over to the White House today I tried to
get some information I know that general
mattis is sending four Navy ships I also
know that they have sent in not only
FEMA
National Guard troops are available to
you and they have pre-positioned as I
understand it post storm all the food
water medicine supplies that that
obviously Floridians are going to be
needing but that's coming up after the
storm in preparation for this storm
explain what you are advising people
because you've actually lifted
regulations to bring in more gasoline so
people could travel to the safer parts
of the state and also what about food
medicine supplies and things like that
starting with starting with food food
and water
we work for retailers to make sure we
have enough good water if a retailer
gets out to replenishing quickly the
fuel we talked about that review there
we're we do have some outages we do have
some lines we do have some people
waiting but we're getting more fuel the
federal government has waived a lot of
regulations to help us in that regard
with regard to medicine I've got a lot
of people to get their medicines early I
got right now two days ago I stopped all
the tolls in the state to make it easier
for people to get through when we did
doesn't you don't get slowed down by the
toes so the we're doing everything we
can FEMA is pre position assets I've
repositioned assets our utilities are
very focused on pre positioning people
to get our power back up as quickly as
possible what I made biggest concerns is
before to Keith because we have so many
bridges down there we lose one bridge
every base transit stop there yeah
governor have you spoken to the
president I've spoken to the president
multiple times over the weekend and this
week I've spoken with the price vice
president spoken to it seems like almost
every cabinet member up there as I've
called it asked for support
there they're doing the things I've
asked for I know the president says he
really hears about this space I know he
does
so I appreciate everybody's help and a
lot of calls from governor's from around
the country that have called it offers
the poured in defense support I'm
appreciative of everything we're doing I
want everybody in my state to stay stay
and survive this will rebuild your will
rebuild your home or rebuild your
possessions we can't rebuild your life
for your family they say all right
governor that's great advice for
everybody
but you know it's my second home our
thoughts and prayers are with you and
we'll be watching closely and I know the
country will be ready with any help
obviously that are our neighbors down
there need thank you for being with us
Thank You Sean all right